[Music]
I'm going to talk a little bit more
about the practical realities of getting
data into those equations and about
actually how we can actually link
suppliers to consumers there's a few
more pictures in mind not very many
formulas very happy to take questions
but we're trying to get a bit more of a
practical practitioners view of actually
how to get data in and how to get it
into a form that can be used so no good
data presentation to start without the
fact that were drowning we don't need to
dwell on this but the amount of data
that I'm seeing you know just every week
it goes up in you know orders of
magnitude to be honest so managing it is
a big deal for all of us let's talk
about this so before I get into this
quick show of hands how many people
consume data how many people provide
data to others how many do both okay
so let's have a look at this slide so a
little bit of a test for you Who am I
talking about on this slide so we're
looking here we're in a data-driven
world we know that getting data to be
but is hugely important and if you want
to have it at your fingertips you
actually have to invest in that we also
know it's hard it's very frustrating you
know we're getting into some of the
pitfalls later on but it's really
difficult to get a team to actually
focus on some what frankly and I
submitted mundane operational processes
to make sure that your pipelines are
working every day how do you get people
to care enough that no data enough how
do you actually get the job done if
you're in the infrastructure world er
you spent any time there there's a good
analogy with networks here if you run
the network in a major bank you can only
ever feel pain no one appreciates you
when you're working and when you're down
everybody hates you the same is true
with data pipelines largely there's
always screaming when they're not there
there's not so much appreciation than
getting the data there and it's a big
part of the job as we go through this
and these things are expensive to build
but are they differentiating well sure
some companies believe they are and the
best do a fantastic job a lot of
companies don't though a lot of
companies are ill-equipped to do this a
lot of companies are frightened to do
this so in a situation that if you don't
keep up you hurt your business if you do
keep up it's a cost or an expense base
that you have to manage because all
you're trying to do is to get that very
last piece to actually do the analysis
generate the signal and margin pressure
comes back that only takes good
recession before I should buddy starts
thinking about the cost structures I
asked the question at the beginning of
this this slide most people assume that
this slide is about consumers and it is
but it's also about suppliers we sit in
the middle as you'll see later on but
the trouble is that suppliers also have
a hard job now I don't have a lot of
sympathy bidding up being on the buy
side of this data business for a very
long time and I've also been a supplier
the suppliers faced similar challenges
how do they keep up with the
technologies to get the data to us in a
way that actually makes sense to us why
do I have to keep investing in all of
these different technologies because the
clients want to in a given wait was an
answer there you want to be paid but
it's still an overhead to the suppliers
to do this just as it is for all of us
to connect into individual suppliers
with a multitude of ways of doing things
because they're just being helpful so
two seconds on the major trends you must
have seen a lot of these type of
pictures to be honest data is getting
bigger and bigger and bigger extracting
signal is becoming more difficult
keeping bias out of the data who is
neutral who is not is becoming a bigger
and bigger deal how do you get data that
you can trust in a way that you can
manipulate how do you get full
provenance of that data how do you prove
that you've actually got the best you've
got and that you know where it came from
pipelines we've all got a lot of these
so let's talk about inefficiency quickly
as a consumer most of the business is
about getting the data in and going
through a number of basic steps if you
actually look at what the definitions
are in the public space you see
80% is a recognized number anywhere
between 65 and 80 depending on which
study you read that says a lot of it is
about doing the plumbing that plumbing
is not easy it's not glamorous it's hard
but it is 80 percent of the time even if
you assumed it was 60 percent of the
time wouldn't you rather be doing data
analysis well actually there is a group
of people that actually enjoys doing the
first bit and that's great we have a lot
of them in our company too but the end
of the day companies in the in their
open space commercial are not really
focused on trying to get the data in
they're trying to focus on getting the
data out and into a signal that they can
use in the most cost-effective way so
it's not that these are easy tasks it's
not they're not valuable to us but they
are non differentiating tasks the job is
actually how do we make sure that we can
get that really easy from the consumers
perspective really easy from a suppliers
perspective and make sure we can join
the two ends of the spectrum here which
is suppliers and clients so pipelines
aren't just the technical problem the
problem that you have with pipelines is
suppliers and technology and contracts
and building relationships how do you
actually get the data if you're in a big
organization there's probably somebody
that does this for you but if you're
going after a small data set from the
small Chinese company how are you going
to do that how are you going to go after
the really big ones that believe that
actually the suppliers pay we give you
the data we set the terms how you're
going to negotiate those relationships
so it's not just about getting the data
in fast it's not just about connecting
to the right technology pipe it's about
actually managing the suppliers
themselves and then this is a sort of a
joke in my family here are puppies not
just for Christmas that's a standard
joke it means that something lasts
forever so a pipeline isn't just for
Christmas either you want to build them
you want to get as much data you end up
with thousands tens of thousands of
these very quickly if you're ingesting
large amounts of data and they all have
to be curated they all have to be looked
after they all have to be run and they
all have to be fixed when somebody
changes the schema without telling you
and you can deliver it so internally
you're probably lucky if you're in an
organization you can put it on
internal site maybe you're going to an
AZ device maybe you go to a DB suppliers
don't have that luxury suppliers have to
do all of it or none of it or you as a
consumer has to bend to actually do this
and that's why we see a multiplicity of
different types of connections
techniques and tools clients are
different bless them some want Paul some
want push some want query some want all
some want it this way it's fair people
want an easy way of ingesting data
you've got to find the right balance to
give the right tools to the right folks
in your organization's to do the job the
trick is the left to the right anything
in between and I'm including data
analysis as well up to a certain degree
is overhead how do you get data in
appropriately quickly regardless of the
techniques obviously I represent
corrupts we're here to try and help that
problem we fill that problem many of us
have been in the industry practicing and
surviving this problem for years but the
key point is to keep the client in mind
we have to get data in the right form to
clients so that they can use the data in
the way that they want to get value out
of the license fees that paid or indeed
to deduce signals from open data so how
do you think about this a little bit
differently well for the data suppliers
you have to think about what they need
so they need to be able to deliver they
need to run trials how difficult if you
guys found it to actually find anyone to
tell you what the schema is of a new
data set before they force you to buy it
how difficult is it to get it exactly
the format that you want how do you meet
the expectations if you're a provider of
the operations teams and your consumers
making sure the data is always available
for you how do you make sure you keep up
we had a great conversation one of the
other partners outside about the access
of databases almost feels like back to
the future
in terms of access to data how do you
keep up with that if you're a small
supplier how do you keep up with it if
you're a big consumer how do you get
more flex in your pipelines on the
consumer side you really would need one
throat to choke
in an ideal world if you didn't worry
about competitive pressures you want the
data in the same way guaranteed so you
can load it you need the right technical
expertise on the data that's coming in
how many of you have dealt with
suppliers where the supplier actually
doesn't know their data I know I have
over the years and I work for a big data
company how do you make sure that you're
scalable does your infrastructure team
maybe you are the infrastructure team
how do you make sure that you're there
for the future that you can really
survive that if there's a big blow of
data coming in I mean I've seen
personally recently some of the files
that were downloading and loading are
like a hundred and thirty gig
that's not huge but it's bigger than the
average data set how do you do that
reliably every day on multiple multiple
multiple systems how do you make sure
that you get the data in the right
format for your consumers how do you
make sure you keep up so in reality we
sort of need an electric grid we need
providers and we need suppliers
basically to publish data we need a
mechanism to cross connect that to the
individual consumers and we also need to
recognize that consumers are also
providers we've seen in certainly our
business very many of the companies that
start as consumers only recognize they
actually have value in their own data
sets and want to get those to market do
we expect companies commercial companies
to start building distribution networks
and started basically working with as if
they were big aggregators I somehow
believe there's a different model that's
required let's talk a little bit about
the engineering time and effort so
engineering starts with time and effort
how do you get the data well the way we
view this it's pretty easy it's a very
easy model to think about it's a
difficult one to implement you've got
supplier engagement you've got to have
conversations with suppliers to get the
data you've got to analyze that data
you've got to work out how to load it
and a lot of that in terms of the time
and effort is often driven by the size
and complexity of the data set I get a
lot of our business how long's onboard a
data set or how long to onboard a
dataset is literally at how long a piece
of string is it depends on frequency
complexity number of data frames can
get access to all the supply give it to
me there's a lot of considerations when
you start thinking about how to build a
team to do this but if you're doing your
own pipelines you have to do this in one
form or another you then got the hard
core data engineering how do you make
sure you've got an infrastructure to
process the data how do you make sure
that you sense the data the instant it's
available if your business is
time-sensitive and you believe that you
need to react quickly and your
competitive edge is driven by processing
quickly you better have a good sensor
infrastructure in place you also better
have a good pipeline infrastructure in
place and you better have a good
distribution infrastructure in place
everybody's doing this again and again
and again and I love the ETL tools I
really think there's some fantastic
stuff out there but those are tools that
we use as well we need those sort of
tools to help us onboard data but
there's so many different ways of
onboarding data and there's always
nuances what you do you can't avoid
having a really good engineering team
sitting behind this to get your
pipelines working and at the end of the
day there's the puppy again how do you
keep all of this working in production
day-in day-out 24/7 just when you think
you want to take the system down you
find a client will suit to keep it up
that long weekend of analysis that you
didn't know you were impacting how do
you make sure it's there when they want
it and underpinning all of this you've
got to get the right team you've got the
right quality you got to get the right
people gotta get the right tools in your
running process this is a business and
whether you're running a business
internally or you're going to someone
like us to actually help you with that
it is a business this is not a hobby you
cannot treat data ingestion as a hobby
if you do you're not doing this
seriously and you're going to end up
frankly probably in a train rank because
this stuff is it gets harder and harder
the more scale you put into it it's
almost impossible to get into this
business by doing it on a casual basis
so I quite like these play on calls or
Aoi versus casual AI that's coming from
this quick peek at us so what have we
done
well pretty standard classic engineering
to be honest we have a strong component
and abstraction architecture we have
your we made brand it a little bit
differently than what you guys have got
but I have a fairly robust ingestion
pipeline which I
deliver which grabs everything in and
pushes it out we have clear adapters to
push things into verse distribution
mechanisms it took us a while to I mean
this is a everybody when you look at
this goes yeah that's a standard
architecture but when you're in up to
your elbows or you're doing this to
start with
you tend to get seduced by other pieces
of technology the big data set that's
there as well the core of our
engineering is solid engineering it's
not the newest tool on the block we use
the right tools for the right job
the core here is to make sure you get
the right abstraction that you can run
pipelines pipeline is a pipeline is a
pipeline from my perspective I want to
run the best the fastest the easiest the
most configurable but I need it in a way
that I can take the output and repurpose
that output this is not difficult Compu
science to get your head round it is
quite hard engineering to get right and
we've used this to our advantage we've
recently introduced publishing our
datasets actually directly out of our
file based your core into databases
relatively straightforward because of
the abstractions and it's going to keep
us nimble and it protects us in terms of
actually new distribution technologies
coming along some will be flavor of the
year some will stick around for a long
time and as we go through this we want
to make sure we got an architecture that
can flex along with it
event architecture this feels like and I
was talking to one of the guys outside
and he was talking about databases now
we don't actually pause for effect
we don't use a core database in our
central system we thought about that and
we moved away from it they've questioned
the problem we face is making sure that
we can insight or data the easiest way
that we structure our data we believe in
data sets we group them together and we
obviously call it a crux delivery unit
as our product that we use to group data
sets and then data frames underneath
them we process those really well and we
entire to our clients at a data set
level and many of you don't have to face
entitlement problems but some of the big
organizations do they want to trace the
entitlements of their data across their
organizations a lot of the really big
banks are centralizing that function are
trying to be an in position where they
run their own
in essence where they can get the data
in one place get economies and
distribute that data out to their
various divisions and keep quite track
good track on who's using what now only
from profitability accountability but
also to make sure that they're actually
entitled to use that data because again
suppliers and companies do not have
singular relationships many of the big
suppliers have multiple relationships of
various divisions of the bigger players
so you've got to keep track of this so
what we do is we get all the files and
we call that crux hub we put an event
architecture around it and we'll come
back to some of the lessons we've
learned as we've got to through this
journey of a vacuum making sure that we
try to make to have an event at the
lowest level so that we can actually
group them together and do processing
based on what our clients need and that
sounds very generic but it's the
equivalent the the hardcore example of
this is if you got a data set that's
made up say at a dozen frames a fairly
small one then some clients want to be
notified when all twelve have actually
completed some clients want them run in
a very specific order and some clients
only want to be notified when number six
is finished so from an engineering
perspective as a supplier I need to go
down to the lowest level of this to try
and support them in that endeavor
so I actually try to make sure events
come out at the lowest level I can which
is effectively at the frame within a
data set level and then we group those
together and we do post processing of
the bank so what you're seeing here is
obviously a very high level architecture
but we have a bus we have a sensor
infrastructure that shakes on websites
if we don't if we're not getting a
defined feed we have a mechanism for
enclosing interesting provenance of say
Chinese supplier loaders that have to be
run in a very secure VM just in case in
order to pass security master we have a
number of different techniques for doing
this and then we basically publish that
into our pipelines and we optimize how a
pipelines process and we group the
output and then we repurpose it in order
to be transmitted to our clients schemas
Hulot schemas schemas are there just for
one thing yeah being changed when you're
not looking so the way we've approached
schemas okay so we have
output resources no well that's a file
or that's a database or whether yeah
it's a stream of data we tend to define
that in a classical sense as a frame of
data so a very specific structure for a
given moment in time what we do is we
define input and output schemas relating
to this we actually show the
relationship between them now we've
stumbled on this historically so we've
put in the fact that we didn't put
precisely what was in the output schema
some of that was hidden in our
processing and we've just remediated
that because knowing exactly what's
coming out exact provenance based on
data if you're a data business you ready
to run yourself on data you need to run
yourself on configuration you cannot you
put this in code and expect it to be
exposed to clients in some other way you
need to be able to actually describe the
schemas and processing through if it was
just this this would be straightforward
unfortunately we have dictionaries to
take into account what goes into the
schemas that's a dictionary from a
supplier it's always right we deal with
some of the biggest data sets on the
market and within that it is sometimes
beyond belief that some of the biggest
providers can't even get their own ID
names spelt the same way in multiple
fields now Locke do but it's not
uncommon to actually have a dictionary
that's actually faulty from the supply
even if they provide one so regardless
of this you need a way of describing
your data to get meaning out of it to
get insight from this so you actually
have to get a dictionary and related to
your schemas very very well or you're
exposing yourself for when this happens
they change it if life was static this
would be hard but not impossible
so the second frame comes along if you
guys are loading data into a database do
you go back and do a database conversion
highly unlikely you might in some cases
you might build a view on top but the
reality of this and typically is you end
up with doing another table and trying
to remember that they're related so
you've got to keep traceability between
the frames and then here's the trick
it's a little bit of the secret sauce
just relate the output schemes if you
can track your output schemas in the
same way to track your input schemas you
have an ability to provide
an insulation layer to yourselves so
this is what we're doing this is how
we're going to basically put schema
protection in place for our clients and
our suppliers so it's again it's both
the suppliers would benefit because they
can do their release schedule as they
wish and the consumers can move on the
adoption pace as they wish if you can
provide complete schema evolution
protection which we believe this can
okay so what have we learned well it's
been a busy six months mean in the
company and I would bring out a few
things pipelines are not the be-all and
end-all they're extremely important but
the start of the problem start off the
solution they're not the end goal
there's no such thing as a standard that
there really isn't I mean I've had a
situation recently where we were
checking affecting the control structure
and we found a bunch of frames for the
probably the biggest supplier out there
and there was no data so obviously it's
our code we check we check no we go back
to the supplier can you tell us these
data frames you don't seem to be
supplying them and this is these are
like 20 or maybe 25 amongst seven and a
half thousand for this one supplier and
their comment was earned no sorry now
we've never had data for those but why
are they in the spec well we might have
data for those are you telling me that
they might appear at some indeterminate
time in the future yes and when you
start looking you start seeing other
suppliers with the same basis how do you
process that how do you make sure you
got the control mechanisms in place to
spot a new frame appearing and then do
something about it because it needs to
be a conscious decision subconsciously
you can do the engineering to
automatically create the frame and the
pipeline's but how do you know what that
data is and how do you do something with
it
insight if we think pipelining gets hard
gaining genuine insight for what the
data really is is much harder what is
this data set many data engineering
groups have become a basis of your
biggest driver in life is to get the
data a client ones that they want it yes
they get it now and you don't have time
to do the thought process
we go through a process where we try to
do that onward
you know the catch the wave of
engineering to get things on but then we
go back and we tidy up we go back and
look at what that datasets are there's
always an ever-increasing backlog there
but getting insight from the data is
significantly harder than doing the
engineering to onboard that data and
then contracting for those of you that
have to do it is frankly they're doing
someone's work these are very hard when
you have an in transient supplier or
you've got a really good one that
doesn't have a tech nerd apartment to
actually help you you've got to get all
of these sorted out for data and then
just when you think it was safe to go
back in the water you have a
conversation with client or your
internal spy about how to get the data
you find that has nuances to we're going
to show you in a second there's we've
actually done quite a bit of work with
snowflake so that's easy you talk to the
first client fantastic talk the second
fight yes we want to try this out you
talk to the third and then you ask that
little question at the end where are you
running it and you find this in a
different cloud and you have to fix that
there's always nuances in terms of
distributions even when you think you've
got this now so if data insights are 101
technologies 102 and 102 for you if you
google it you'll find it's basically a
banking response for the system's down
so hopefully that's not an analogy for
this so look at this not everything is a
big data problem okay that's linked to
the next one it's not every solution
needs a big data at all it's very easy
to be seduced into thinking that because
you're doing data and because it's
really big that you need all the bells
and whistles you need to spark
infrastructures you need to have you
know dynamic dispatch it's just not true
the baselines of hard core pipelines is
solid engineering now you can do it in
many ways we've chosen event based
structures to do it but you don't
necessarily need the state of the art
all bleeding edge technology in order to
do things if you're doing analysis I
will give you that actually on the
analysis side of the house perhaps you
do perhaps bigger engines we're still
effectively data stores that can span
multiple petabytes I get that but for
ingestion
pipelines use the right tool mature
technologies have their place okay it's
not bad to use Excel with an ODBC driver
to look at your data okay it's not bad
to use my sequel for your corporate
reference data okay you might want to
use Cassandra in other places you might
want to use bigquery you might want to
use snowflake there are many options for
you to do but don't throw out some of
them are your pure technologies to
pillage your pipelines and to build your
infrastructure there's a lot of goodness
there it's been there for many years and
it's a good risk bias against some of
the newer technologies focus on your own
data what are the atoms what do you
process I mean genuinely we've gone down
the stack up the set I have more
arguments with my data staff and tech
staff about the structure of how we
process than necessarily any of the data
we process it's really important to
understand what your basic atomic unit
is that you're processing and optimize
around there certainly as a supplier
there's an important piece of the
pipeline infrastructure I want to be
really well at the very smallest thing
we do and I want to roll that up later
which goes on to the next bit name early
and bind late get your naming structures
sorted out up front I would defy anyone
to on board something like the larger
data sets out the risk models the
financial fundamental models without
getting a naming structure agreed and it
sounds silly it's really important you
need to be able to make your data sets
digestible to your consumers you need to
make sure they can actually be pulled
down and found discovering the day that
you've on-boarded is almost the biggest
problem as onboarding it in the first
place making sure that you have a decent
catalog that people can actually
programmatically access so they can find
the right table with the right with the
right data in it or find indeed the
right field inside the right file that
they downloaded for a delivery last year
or how do you handle your histories
really important to do that get the
naming done straight and then to bind
your actual runtime infrastructure to
that very late in the game the more you
can do that and the more flexibility you
get lies damned lies and column names
I'm sure with all
of this I will absolutely execute the
next supplier that puts double quotes in
a column name
you can't sir actually manage this stuff
of which this is the real world it's
it's mind-boggling to me how many
suppliers do not take into account what
the client is going to see now I'm a
proxy for the client in many cases I
take the data in and I cleanse it I fill
this pain I feel your pain on this we've
got to get better education out there in
the industry about what's accept or
what's not acceptable to make everyone's
life just that little bit easier no
matter what you do your architecture
needs to flex no matter what you do
you'll make wrong decisions
the only guarantee in life is whatever
you built would not actually work
completely for every use case you've got
make sure you've got a process in place
that allows you to flex David
duplication is not solving the clients
problem which is a bit of an interesting
statement from us as we actually make
sure that we move data we duplicate data
in essence from the supplier all the way
through to the client it's necessary
there are better models but everybody
has to get to those better models if
they want to do it we want to help the
industry have a lifeblood to get that
and then also support more sharing
options the ability to actually share
not to placate data literacy to query it
but you've got to get the data in order
to query it that's what we come in and
two last points dictionaries a little
bit like earlier you must curate them
you can't they just won't organically
happen you need to understand the
cross-referencing you need to be able to
make sure that you know how to join two
different data sets
most of the bane of people's lives I've
got this set from Bloomberg I've got
this set from MSC I how do I join them
how do you get that sort of information
out how do you provide that information
to your users and the last one a little
bit tongue-in-cheek yeah
you can't automate stupidity but you can
actually use automation to spot
stupidity make sure you clean your
pipelines the data coming in there's an
old adage in data architecture which is
get the data right at source if it's not
right at source clean it as fast as you
can as it comes in
okay last slide go into Data Karma keep
it simple it's really really hard
it's very easy to get complex most of
the people in this business can handle
complexity and there's a tendency to
overcomplicate the answers make the
engineering as simple as you possibly
can question them I have scars for
questioning it with my own teams but it
pays off you're able to build components
that will scale with you consistency
wherever you can try to make it
consistent this is sounds like
motherhood and apple pie and it is but
it's so true if you are good at
processing pipelines you better be able
to define pipelines consistently if you
want to be able to distribute data you
better have a plug in infrastructure
that allows you to do that
or a very big engineering budget and a
lot of tolerance and probably a lot of
value and the last point is as being
obviously a Brit I'm a fond of this
slide in terms of Keep Calm be paranoid
if it's going to happen if you think it
can't happen in the data sets you're
processing it will happen every day I
feel like I'm saying I can't believe it
but every day there's some think that
jumps out and you need an infrastructure
that could support that fright moment
has a way of coping with it and plugging
it back in and I think I've only gone
one minute over so thank you happy to
take questions and there's an office
hour 3:15 upstairs if anyone wants to
talk
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]